wir kommen gern preis ich kann nicht
atmen
die letzten worte des 46-jährigen afro
amerikaners george floyd bevor er starb
lag das knie eines polizisten über acht
minuten mit vollem körpergewicht auf
seinem hals kreuz gewaltsamer tod ende
mai markierte beginnt einer welle von
demonstrationen und ausschreitungen die
von den usa aus mittlerweile die gesamte
westliche welt erfasst hat
sie fordert ein ende als so gängiger
rassistischer praktiken gerade auf
seiten der polizei
worin sich dieser rassismus zeigt wie
vielschichtig erwirkt und natürlich auch
wir zu überwinden wäre daher will ich
zunächst mit vanessa thompson sprechen
die soziologin an der goethe universität
frankfurt vorschlag über rassismus
migration und polizeigewalt gegen
schwarze menschen in der gruppe franzen
herzlich willkommen dieses video das
geht uns alle an wenn man es sieht es
geht uns auch nach wann haben sie zum
ersten mal von diesem fall erfahren und
wie haben sie darauf als mensch und
nicht als forscherin reagiert sofern
sich das trennen lässt also ich habe das
video zum ersten mal gesehen und da muss
ich dazu sagen dass ich mir gar nicht
ganz zu ende anschauen konnte 22 tage
nach der tötung von george flirt das ist
ja auch sehr stark in den sozialen
medien kursiert und ich konnte es mir
beim ersten mal gar nicht komplett
anschauen wir sehen hier die tötung
eines menschen der um sein leben gefleht
das ist glaube ich und das schmerzt vor
allem aber auch weil es ist sehr
schmerzlich und und auch erdrückend und
fürchterlich aber besonders dieser
letzte satz i can't brief ist ein
einsatz der deutlich macht wie stark und
tief sitzend die erfahrung des nicht
atmen können es eigentlich in schwarze
erfahrung global eingeschrieben ist
das ist ja auch mehr als nur eine
zustandsbeschreibung es ist ja eine
metapher dafür überhaupt frei sein zu
können
ungefragt sein zu können das atmen als
idee von freiem da sein und das ist
würden sie sagen ein zentrum der
schwarzen erfahrung dass man dieses frei
man nicht hat nicht genau also ich
glaube es ist nicht umsonst so dass der
satz erkennt brief jetzt wieder erneut
so eine kraft auch erlangt hat im rahmen
der proteste von black lifes matter
transnational gesehen also nicht nur in
den usa aber 2014 bei dem fall
amerikaner hat dieser satz auch schon
ganz viel widerhall gefunden und auch
historisch hat dieser satz eine gewisse
bedeutung also ein transfer der kritiker
hat bereits in seinem werk die
verdammten dieser erde von der
verunmöglichen der systematischen
verunmöglichen von atmen gesprochen im
rahmen seiner analyse des kolonialismus
und ich verstehe die verunmöglichen von
atmen als eine symbolische aber auch
materielle metapher weil wir zum
beispiel auch bei fans racial profiling
sehen also willst da zum beispiel in der
schweiz der gewürgt wurde von der
polizei und auch gesagt hat ich kann
nicht mehr atmen
samo dorf in der in finnland von der
polizei getötet wurde hat auch gerufen
ich kann nicht mehr atmen
aber auch die kleineren formen des
wäsche profilings das auf der hut sein
müssen vor der polizei das wegrennen vor
der polizei macht alles was mit atmung
wir haben es schon angesprochen es gibt
viele fälle es gibt eine lange
geschichte dieser fälle und noch eine
längere vorgeschichte
was ist jetzt an diesem fall aus ihrer
sicht anders dass er solch eine massive
reaktion und vor allem auch eine
internationale reaktion
also ich denke zum einen dass wir
natürlich gerade sehen wie sich in den
in den usa multiple krisen
kristallisieren also unter jetzt im
rahmen der korona pandemie hat sich
gezeigt dass besonders schwarze menschen
sehr stark betroffen sind auch da hier
das atmen als eine kern angst des
menschen genau und gleichzeitig müssen
sie noch um diese kriminalisierung
fürchten
ja und es ist aber auch dass das jetzt
zeigt dieser moment der krisen dass
einerseits die arbeit von black life
center die ja auch schon
sich 2013 gegründet hat schnell auch
international widerhall gefunden hat
natürlich dass das zeigt das kann jetzt
viel schneller mobilisiert werden und
aber auch es auch zeigt also sehen wir
auch in den slogans enough is enough es
reicht das unheimlich viel bereitschaft
jetzt ist dagegen einzustehen und
widerstand zu zeigen gegen etwas was
auch historisch gesehen kein ende
genommen
also eine spezifische konstellation in
der viele dinge zueinander finden sodass
sich die erfahrung auch der protest
konzentriert sie forschen über
projizieren gegen schwarze menschen in
europa das ist ein begriff den man
vielleicht auch erst mal erklären was
bedeutet und wo hin zeigt sich dieses
produzieren also publizieren bezeichnet
ein gesellschaftliches kräfteverhältnis
der kontrolle und kriminalisierung was
historisch sehr weit zurückgeht und
gegenwärtig auch noch weiter in
institutionen aber auch gesellschaftlich
sowie auf der subjektiven ebene wirkt
also beides eine institutionelle form
und auch eine form die jeden von uns
selbst betrifft und auch ausgeübt wird
von jedem fall genau
natürlich können wir mit dem dem ansatz
des politikers die institution polizei
analysieren die techniken strukturen
gesetzgebungen aber publizieren selbst
geht über die institution polizei hinaus
und bettet sie eigentlich ein in das
gesellschaftliche verhältnis und schaut
sich auch an auf der subjektiven ebene
für wen bedeutet polizei eigentlich
sicherheit und schutz und für wenig und
das mit gängiger erfahrung von schwarzen
menschen oder people auf carla persons
auf carla dass die polizei eigentlich
gar keine schutzmacht für sie ist in der
ersten warnung sondern eine bedrohung
macht das geht auch sehr weit zurück da
muss ich glaube ich dazu sagen das ist
jetzt nicht einfach eine kontinuität die
hat natürlich auch brüche wir haben es
mit verschiedenen polizeilichen
paradigma zu tun auch rassismen ändern
sich obwohl die funktionsweise gleich
bleibt wesentlich gleich historisch geht
das schon sehr weit zurück in den usa
hat das natürlich ganz stark auch mit
der versklavung zu tun also die
entstehung der polizei wie wir sie
kennen in den usa 19 jahrhundert war
ganz stark geknüpft
die praxis des anfangs vom fass klafften
menschen kontrollieren auf plantagen
rückte man sagen die geburt der polizei
aus dem geiste der sklaverei ist das ist
das eine formulierung die historisch
richtig ist die moderne polizei ja also
ich denke die polizei wie sie jetzt
kennen als die moderne polizei die sich
im neunzehnten jahrhundert praktisch
manifestiert hat da wurden ganz viele
praktiken auch in diese moderne
institution überführt die mit
versklavung aber auch kolonialismus und
hier kommt europa ins spiel weil immer
die frage ist gibt es das so in europa
natürlich müssen wir historische
nationale regionale unterschiede
betrachten
gleichzeitig hat sich das publizieren im
rahmen europas und das hat auch verlor
aber viele andere auch sehr gut in
analysiert sehr stark in den
europäischen kolonien abgespielt also
wir können gar nicht über die genese der
modernen polizei in europa nachdenken
ohne die kolonialen laboratorien mit
das ist eine ganz wichtige kontinuität
die viele wahrscheinlich gar nicht vor
augen haben das ist eine
weiterentwicklung eine fortentwicklung
von dem kolonialen beherrschungs technik
in unser polizeiwesen hinein gibt ein
wichtiger effekt sie brachen das schon
eines der ace dass racial profiling das
heißt im kern gesagt wohl dies dass
menschen schwarzer hautfarbe an sich
verdächtig erscheinen als andere und
daher auch häufiger in verdachts
kontroll momente in bestrafungs kontexte
einbezogen werden genau und das ist auch
nicht nur in den usa so da sehen wir es
ganz stark an den an der praxis des
racial profiling sondern auch in europa
und vor allem sehen wir hier auch das so
ab der mitte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts wo die dekolonisierung und
die koloniale arbeitsmigration auch noch
mal die bevölkerungsstruktur in europa
verändert hat sehen wir zunehmend
widerstände gegen rassistische polizei
praktiken die sich in ihrer alltäglichen
dimension vor allem im rahmen des
profilings zeigen also das heißt der
kontrolle als auch dem anhalten dem
durchsuchen von menschen die als
krimineller gesehen werden und das hat
ganz starke psycho soziale effekte
konsequenzen für menschen und hält sie
aber auch in ihrem alltäglichen sein und
dem nachgehen ihres alltäglichen lebens
eigentlich an und das hat natürlich auch
eine wirkung auf die gesellschaften ja
also die gesellschaft die die polizei
eigentlich als zu schützende oder auch
sicherheit bringen der institution sieht
kann sich dann auch denken also so
werden dann auch gesellschaftliche
rassismen eigentlich manifestiert diese
gruppen sind ja auch personeller
vielleicht haben sie auch irgendwann
übernimmt das als verdacht auch als
eigenes subjekt drin rassismus und
rassistische packen sind ja ein
dialogisches verhältnis in gewisser
weise es gibt ein opfer und es gibt auch
einen täter wenn man ihre arbeiten ließ
gibt es ein sehr eindrückliche
formulierung sie nennen das den weißen
blick in anschluss anfangs fanden diese
weise blick ist ein alltags raster blick
den ich wahrscheinlich auch mit meiner
selbst wertung verinnerlicht habe worin
zeigt er sich im alltag also ich denke
vielleicht noch mal kunst dieser weiße
blickt ist eigentlich ein
klassifikationssystem dass entlang von
rassistischen hierarchisierung menschen
kategorisiert also da werden
wertigkeiten erzeugten weine mensch ist
mehr wert als der andere ja und es
werden bestimmte bedeutungen
eingeschrieben in gruppen zum beispiel
das schwarze menschen öfters oder mehr
drogen konsumieren oder dylan oder
irgendwie krimineller sein ja oder dass
menschen die als muslimische gelesen
sein irgendwas mit terror zu tun haben
müssen und was da interessantes ist das
zeigt sich auch dann an den
polizeilichen kontrollen dass dieser
weiße blick auch auf einer subjektiven
ebene wirkt nämlich das ja
mehrheitsgesellschaftern sich eigentlich
mit diesem weißen blick auch
identifizieren und denken es muss ja
sein auch ermächtigen gleichsam raus
objekte während dieser weise blick
gleichzeitig andere gruppierungen
unterdrückt besonders jene die von der
gleichzeitigkeit von ungleichheiten
betroffen sind also schwarze menschen
die aus sozioökonomisch schwächeren
milieus kommen die illegalisiert sind
ein prekären aufenthaltsstatus haben
da merkt man auch noch mal wie die
verschränkung von ungleichheiten wirkt
aber ich denke das ist auch ganz wichtig
dass es beim polizzi 'ran was über ein
dessen blick läuft das heißt über die
klassifizierung von gruppen dass es eine
komplementäre klassifizierte ergänzen
sich also genau es geht nicht nur um
diesen krimineller sondern die anderen
werden gleichzeitig damit auch geraten
nicht in generalverdacht fühlen sich
sicher durch diese kontrollen
das heißt wir müssen das viel als viel
verschränkter denken als das oft
thematisiert wird und auch dann die
frage stellen welche rolle spielen
eigentlich welche rolle spielt die
normalisierung des sich sicher führen
stück im rahmen der polizei da drinnen
und wie sind wir eigentlich alle
eingewoben in dieses verhältnisses
polizei dieses sicherheitsversprechen
das immer schon eine wertigkeit in sich
trägt so würdig zu verstehen das ist
vielleicht ein guter zeitpunkt unseren
zweiten gast zuzuschalten aus washington
dem politikwissenschaftler charme
verliert an der harvard universität und
der johns hopkins universität hemmung
vielen dank dass wir so früh in neuer
welt für uns zur verfügung stehen sie
haben ein buch geschrieben das laut der
dessen titel lautet auf deutsch der
zerfall der demokratie wie der
populismus den rechtsstaat bedroht wenn
man den ausführungen von frau thompson
volk könnte man sagen es gibt noch eine
andere große bedrohung des rechtsstaates
und der demokratie das ist der interne
rassismus der sich durch das projizieren
zeigt würden sie dem zustimmen gerade
mit blick auf die usa ja ich denke es
geht zu unterscheiden zwischen zwei
verschiedenen bedrohungen der
demokratien des rechtsstaates eine ist
ein phänomen das es seit der lancken
gibt also man könnte das sich vorstellen
wie eine art fortgeführt das schon immer
an unserem politischen start gehabt hat
und das ist ja das ist dabei ist es
wichtig zu konstatieren dass trotz der
großen probleme die es natürlich
weiteren gibt sich dieses problem
sicherlich nicht verschlimmert hat also
es ist sehr schwer sich die usa
anzuschauen und zu sagen das
das war heute rassistischer sei dass es
schwarze menschen die sind land heute
schlimmer als vor 60 oder auch nur vor
30 jahren trotzdem ist es natürlich eine
echte einschränkung bis zu welchem punkt
das land wirklich für alle seine bürger
gleich und demokratisch ist auf der
anderen seite würde ich sagen ist der
populismus der eine fiel neuere
bedrohung ist der wenn ich den rassismus
mit einem krebsgeschwür verglichen haben
vielleicht mehr wie ein herzinfarkt wird
in dem menschen politiker die den
rechtsstaat die die grundlinien der
demokratie angreifen wollen plötzlich
sehr viel macht haben plötzlich sehr
viel einfluss haben und das ist durch
eine andere bedrohung
zwischen diesen beiden bedrohungen gibt
es eine verbindung das bedeutet
natürlich menschen die rassistischer
sind die gegenüber einwanderungen
gegenüber minderheiten größere
ressentiments haben stimmen in größerer
anzahl für diese populistischen parteien
also die beiden sachen vollkommen
voneinander isoliert da darf ich da
gleich nachfragen weil die konstellation
die auch von thomson beschrieben hat die
jetzt so besonders ist ist ja auch
dadurch entstanden dass der verdacht
entsteht dass der populismus unter
rassismus in gestalt von donald trump
eingeführt werden das rassistische
vorurteile und das spiel mit
rassistischen ressentiments ein
integraler teil des populistischen
programms des derzeitigen präsidenten
sind natürlich und die proteste wegen
dem tod von dort freut und wegen den
praktiken der polizei richten sich bis
zum bestimmten punkt natürlich auch an
den präsidenten der vereinigten staaten
der ganz klar versucht so gut ist
möglich gesellschaftliche spannungen
noch einmal zu vertiefen auf einmal zu
provozieren der ganz klar symbolisch
auch wenn der pro forma
den mord an sechs leute verurteilt hat
sondern auch der seite dieser
rassistischen praktiken steht
und insofern ist diese protestbewegung
ganz klar
sowohl gegen den rechtspopulismus als
auch gegen rassismus gewandelt frau
konnte sich ja auch verwandtschaft in
den usa
es gibt nun zwei lesarten dieser neuen
dynamik die eine ist dass dass sich ein
großer schub innerhalb des wahlkampfs
geschehens gegen trump ist die anderes
ist dass diese eskalation unter
umständen kalkuliert trump dienen könnte
eine ausnahme situation wird erzeugt und
die law and order politik für die er
steht gewinnt noch mehr an attraktivität
wie würden sie dieses
spannungsverhältnis beschreiben
also ich denke dass das natürlich eine
befürchtung sein kann die ganz
realistisch ins ja also gerade bei bei
dieser person trump ich glaube aber auch
dass diese proteste aufgrund ihrer
stärke aufgrund der solidarischen
formationen die sich da gerade nochmal
bilden auch wirklich die möglichkeit als
auch die notwendigkeit beinhalten für
eine grundlegende rhesus thematische
transformation und ich glaube da muss
man sich jetzt auch anschauen wie wird
es politisch aufgenommen
wie verhalten sich auch irgendwie
politiker innen dazu zu diesen protesten
und wie wird es dann auch weitergehen
egal ob jetzt kommt wieder gewählt also
es ist natürlich nicht egal aber selbst
unter joe biden also die black lace meta
bewegung hat sich unter obama gegründet
ja es ist jetzt nicht dass der rassismus
den ich auch nicht mit einem
krebsgeschwür vergleichen will weil
rassismus gehört zu den modernen
demokratischen gesellschaften dazu kann
man ihnen als krieg dafür brauche ich
eine sache sondern hat also sie sagen
herr renter inhärent in die moderne
gesellschaft demokratischen
gesellschaften eingeschrieben und ich
glaube das muss müssen wir erst
anerkennen um irgendwie vielleicht auch
etwas daran verändern sich der dezent
ist ja sehr interessant und wollen wir
erst mal so stehen lassen
hamburg ich sprach mit ihrer kollegin
apple waren vor etwa einem jahr und da
ging es um die wehrhaftigkeit der
amerikanischen demokratie
sie war damals noch sehr optimistisch
ich habe in den letzten zwei wochen von
ihnen tweets
sagen sie ich bin nur noch verzweifelt
ich weiß nicht mehr was ich sagen soll
haben sie jetzt in dieser situation auch
mit den eskalationen wirtschaftskrise
corona begleiter bewegungen das gefühl
dass es eine art ausnahmezustand und
einen verlust der demokratie in den usa
geben könnte
also dachte ich doch gerne ganz kurz auf
autos beantworten denn ich denke wenn
man sagt der rassismus inhärenter teilte
demokratie was bedeutet dass das
bedeutet dass man die beiden niemals
getrennt
ich glaube dass ist zu pessimistisch in
dem fall besonders entweder entscheiden
die demokratie aufzugeben oder auch
immer an rassistischen zu haben da bin
ich optimistisch ich denke es ist
möglich den rassismus freunde demokratie
zu trennen
obwohl es natürlich noch nicht eine
demokratie gegeben hat die vom rassismus
borken frei gewesen wäre
aber sie zusammen zu denken ist dann zu
denken dass die beiden seiten sich
einander bedingen ist glaube ich sowohl
für sich als auch als auch politisch
nicht sehr zielführend weil dann seien
die leute also ein herunter teil der
demokratie ist muss mich entscheiden ob
nicht rassismus tolerieren oder aber die
demokratie aufgebe das ist glaube ich
politisch nicht sehr zweck führend was
die langfristige frage nach der
amerikanischen demokratie angeht bin ich
natürlich in diesem moment verzweifelt
sowohl was amerikas scheitern bei der
chorakademie angeht als auch was diese
furchtbare conthey gewalt angeht es ist
eine sehr deprimierende moment im land
aber ich denke es gibt in der
gesellschaft letztlich viel größeren
konsens als es die politische diskussion
als es die eliten manchmal zu denken
scheint es gibt zb 89 prozent der
amerikanischen bevölkerung die dafür
sind dass david j j umgebracht hat für
mord brand werden soll
donna kommt ist nicht nur unbeliebt er
ist was fragen von rassismus angeht
unbeliebter als wenn es zum beispiel um
kroner geht also wenn es zum beispiel um
die wirtschaft geht
das bedeutet die idee dass er über
diesen
es muss wieder gewählt wird halte ich
nicht für realistisch insofern habe ich
momentan trotz meiner depression über
die amerikanischen verhältnisse größere
hoffnung das hat schon abgewählt wird
und mit großer mehrheit abgewählt wird
als ich es in vier jahren gehabt zu
dieser einschätzung sollte ich ihn kurz
noch ein bild zeigen weil diese bilder
haben ja eine große macht und donald
trump erzeugt diese bilder mit einer
gewissen intention ich wollte ihnen
dieses bild zeigen dass sind milizen auf
den stufen des lincoln memorial lincoln
ein wichtiger präsident der usa der auch
für die abschaffung der sklaverei eine
rolle spielte was will mit dieser
ästhetik gesagt werden und was glauben
sie das würde mich die frage an beide
interessieren
wie wird das in amerika wahrgenommen als
versprechen der ordnung oder als
bedrohung eines militär staates ich
denke ein bisschen was von beidem also
was gerne fragen offen der betriebsrat
von law & order und es gibt durchaus
historische präsident fälle in denen
proteste eher der rechten als der linken
zu gute gekommen ist in den usa nach der
ermordung von matten verkennen 1968 gab
es viele zum teil auch gewalttätige
proteste und richard nixon hat das sehr
clever ausgenutzt um zu sagen ich bin
derjenige der hier wieder für ordnung
sorgen kann und deshalb sollte unbedingt
für mich wählen und es gibt ein sehr
interessantes neues thema von oma was
auf das ist ein split wissenschaftler in
den usa
der zeigt dass gerade weil die töpfe die
nahe an diesen gewaltsamen protesten
daten mit viel größerer prozentzahl für
nächsten gestimmt haben als solche
wahlbezirke die weiter entfernt gewesen
sind das ist die sorge für diesen moment
aber ich denke was an tand bezeichnet
ist ist dass er nicht so wie nächsten
den amerikanern versprechen kann er
würde dafür sorgen dass das land ein
bisschen zur ruhe zurückkehrt denn er
ist in sich selbst in seiner natur ein
ich glaube was leute in amerika sehen
bei diesen bildern ist nicht jemand der
für recht und ordnung sorgen soll was
durchaus sehr beliebt der in den usa
sondern jemand der selber provozierte
das land militarisiert der immovesta
nation
es gibt den ofen ist das gilt für seine
eigenen zwecke nicht frau konnte es gibt
ja innerhalb dieser dynamik jetzt eine
forderung die polizei nicht ganz
abzuschaffen aber dass sie doch
staatsreform ihre napoli zionismus nennt
sich das macht sich gerade in der stadt
in der es passiert ist in minneapolis
breites wurde dafür bestimmt was genau
ist die forderung sie kann ja nicht
darin legen jegliche form von
sicherheitskräften staatlicher art
abzuschaffen
es ist sehr interessant also dass diese
forderung weil die zionistische bewegung
gibt es in den usa schon sehr lange sie
sind auch direkt mit der forderung der
abschaffung von versklavung verknüpft
und sie ich denke kriegen jetzt auch
gerade so einen zuspruch weil viele
teile der bevölkerung genau das bild was
sie gerade gezeigt haben als bedrohung
der demokratie sehen und da noch mal
zurück zu spielen geht es auch nicht
darum rassismus gibt es nur rassistische
demokratien und keine anderen sondern es
ist praktisch der anspruch an eine
demokratie dass sie die ratifizierten
wird genauso wie die dekolonisierung als
ideale andere und im abi zionismus geht
es vor allem darum alternativen zu
schaffen für repressive institution die
nicht reformierbar sind und dafür füllen
sie die polizei erzählen
es geht gar nicht so darum wie ich das
fehlen würde also ich sag jetzt nur wie
die evolution ist ische perspektive ist
die sagt es muss alternativen geben und
das kann alternativen geben die stärker
institutionen stärken der sozialen
teilhabe sozialpolitischer gerechtigkeit
ökonomische gerechtigkeit anstatt immer
nur weiter zu bestrafen und zu
kriminalisieren und wir sehen dass
gesellschaften die sozioökonomische
teilhabe progressive bildungsprojekte
haben auch geringere kriminalitätsraten
haben als gesellschaften in denen ganz
viel aus den sozialen und
bildungsprojekten abgezogen wird und in
militarisiert
polizeiapparat investiert wird an meine
beiden gäste werden nur noch eineinhalb
minuten deswegen eine kurze frage der
philosoph john juli hat gesagt die
probleme der demokratie löst man durch
mehr demokratie
was sind denn in dieser situation in der
sie jetzt als amerikaner und wir hier in
gewisser weise auch stecken ihre großen
hoffnungen aus dieser situation was
würden sie im idealfall als ausgang
sehen und sich wünschen vor trotzdem
zuerst also wirklich ein händler davis
und details nennen viele westliche
liberale demokratien rassistische
demokratien und ich würde gerne für eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche ich würde gerne
ein gesamtgesellschaftliches
langfristiges konsequentes einstehen für
eine nicht rassistische und die
kolonisierten demokratie hemmung ich
denke dass die grundwerte des
politischen systems richtig sind die
meinungsfreiheit die freiheit für den
einzelnen die politik selbstbestimmung
was ich mir aus diesem moment wünsche
ist dass diese werte endlich auf alle
menschen die unseren ländern leben
gleichwertig angewendet werden ein
wichtiges ein schwieriges thema wir
haben heute hoffentlich nicht nur die
oberfläche gekratzt sondern ein bisschen
unsere augen dafür öffnen können wie
komplex das thema ist herr munk vielen
dank nach washington und frau tanzen
vielen dank dass sie heute bei uns dann
nächste woche heißt es jugend gegen alt
barbara bleisch diskutiert die
generationenfrage am philosophischen
stammtisch und jetzt gleich im anschluss
zeigen wir den 90-minütigen
preisgekrönten film einem neuen niveau
ein blick zurück auf die geschichte des
rassismus in der usa 21 zwanzigsten
jahrhundert sowie auf einflussreiche
figuren der bürgerrechtsbewegung erzählt
in den worten des schriftstellers james
ball bin absolut sehenswert bleiben sie
also dran und denken sie weiter
[Musik]